who saw the film for the first time last
night everybody what was it like
watching it with your your fellow losers
and an audience well unfortunately we
didn't sit right next to each other so
we didn't get to see like our reactions
to certain scenes so that was behind I
can look at her I kept I didn't know
that we kissed I was like but even like
after the movie we all just like huddled
together and we're like we love you like
we all just said I love you we shared I
love yous just because it's been such an
incredible journey for us and yeah
everyone involved so we hope it comes
through on screen as well it's crazy
because it's only been two films but
everybody feels so connected to this
cast I mean how does how does the losers
Club continue off screen after this are
you guys gonna have losers Club meetups
or no never seen whenever we're done
really no well yeah but between the
first one in the second one we always
kept in contact we always tried to meet
each other up I mean we we all live in
such different laces that sometimes can
be hard but I think you know every
single time we we get in the same spot
we always try to hang out we see each
other like it's kind of weird we all
live in so many different areas but I
feel a we keep running into each other
because yeah love each other so much you
know you can just kind of put the energy
it's just us the world yeah I never feel
like I and therefore like I really miss
any part of the group yeah it's always
every day every day for like three years
yeah crazy
thanks to Wyatt watching the film does
it become even more apparent how amazing
the adult casting I mean we thought they
were amazing even whenever they were
first guy said but seeing in one screen
last night was just like such a
wonderful thing
mannerisms compared to ours it's just it
was really immersive it was really
awesome now I heard there was when you
got you guys film scenes for the movie
but I heard there was like some D aging
going on what's the what the team whoa
we shot that many years ago and then we
had puberty got different looking and
our voices dropped bodies changed and so
they had to do a little changing but not
for me that's it
I like the same name over all my body
and my voice relatively stayed the same
so I was the only one who one of the
only ones you had I think I had the
least amount of work done to me stay the
same we couldn't hold together guys
Jeremy I want to single you out for a
minute okay because you're doing
something I'm very excited about are you
afraid of the dark so I made it for the
approval of the midnight society oh can
you give me a little update on that
project and what it's like to be a part
of are we getting callbacks yeah I'm
excited
it's uh it'll definitely be nostalgic
for the people that watched it in the
90s and we just finish filming it it'll
be out in mid-october and it's
definitely new for me I'll be playing a
very different character from Ben so I
think you guys will like it